before you became Cedric the Entertainer
well we were all different things right
but you were such a good claims adjuster
oh yeah how do you end up working in
insurance
oh girl living and I want to see it I
work for state power I worked for State
Farm I was a good company yeah okay farm
you were in good hands how did you talk
to people about their accident oh man
I've considered myself bilingual because
I spoke regular English and angry Negro
that's the black people come in and
threaten you the most about oh you gonna
fix this right here everybody likes Ted
and I like Brooke come here come here
man you know you calm down yeah bro you
people want they cars totaled for a
little of nothing so they can get a new
car absolutely but I was really I was I
was not a good claims adjuster because I
was starting my comedy career at the
same time so I would leave people in
rental cars a very long time like which
was good if you look like wanting to
ride around in a cool new car somebody
might be in a rental car to this day
right now did you enjoy because I
enjoyed some of my previous jobs I
really like some of them it was it was a
good job because I got you know you had
the office and then you would get out
sometimes cuz you have to go around and
see people stuff it like shops to make
sure they were working so that was fun
but then I sold equipment I mean like
electronics for Best Buy that one time
another great job that was I was most
embarrassed I was an adult I graduated
from college but I didn't get a job
right away and I had a paper route I
through the Wall Street Journal and so
like nostalgic and endearing like a
paperboy that's cool
yeah but I was grown out like 27
[Applause]
when it was not but my mother was like
not paying my car insurance so I had to
get the money from somewhere but what
you do would be ghost oh my gosh I've
done everything I have sold that well
for one day I trained and then I sold
Kirby vacuum cleaners for $1 because I
was like what like we just throw dirt on
swords for the man was not happy I left
I went to a gas station and my friend
pick me up
I've where actually I was a [ __ ] to
issues at a comedy club for years hi you
know I've worked at a pizza joint Papa
John's
I've worked everywhere you can zhuzh
I've worked it I've worked in a zoo
I worked at the zoo and here's the thing
I was so excited about it but Texas heat
that's not real fun right and so you're
outside and I was new and they put me by
the monkeys wait so so I was like that's
so adorable and then I got there and the
whole place just smells like monkey poo
the whole yeah I'm just breathing in and
it was no you know monkeys yeah I wasn't
that close flags will throw it at you I
do love the zoo though I think the zoo
is awesome but anyway we heard you love
State Bar no without a final performance
review so obviously we wanted to clean
this up for you right so we invited your
Oh boss Darryl Anderson to take care
when Darryl
[Applause]
like around the office when we
interviewed Cedric I mean he came in
with so much energy he was so
comfortable talking with people we knew
he'd be a great fit so we we had no
problem bringing him in performance
review because I'd like you to on a
scale of one to five Darrell how was he
a customer service because that
somebody's maybe still driving out of
the Malibu rut you know I would give him
a five simply because he worked in a
tough environment where there were
people coming in most of the time people
weren't happy when he came in yeah and
after they talked with Cedric they
always left with a smile
[Applause]
how was he getting customers in and out
well I mean I probably would give them
award on that one day and that was only
because I don't think he missed an
opportunity to work on a routine or some
of his jokes so we're a little bit
longer than they need to be talked a lot
too I get it yeah do you agree with that
yeah that's a pretty good assessment
because but we would also have these
little rooms where you go and kind of
talk to people and then once you get
somebody in there you can just like what
are you from you know what my cousin
went to that school and then you don't
like this thing you know you awfully
that I would definitely have files he
could tell you this too because I would
just let stuff pile up because I did
comedy at night so I would come into
work just dog-tired so it would be days
when it would just be claims just piled
up on my desk and he would have to get
other people to come help me like kind
of service my claims people be calling
in that Darrell
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this